I'm talking today with Gustav grunden of
o2 Czech Republic Gustav you took part
here at the ftth council event today on
an executive panel one of the subjects
being copper versus fiber tell me what
the outcome was yes I don't think we
reached a conclusion I think you rarely
do in these discussions but I think it's
never ending debates on on the value of
copper and the role of copper is taking
a slightly different shift I think it is
important to remember that copper has
been declared dead again and again and
again 1972 we had a transmission limit
of 2,400 boards it wasn't even called
bits per second of that I was put boards
and that was considered to be the
absolute maximum 1978 we had 19.2
kilobits but this was really really
really the maximum and so it's gone on
and but what has happened now is that in
order to increase the speed of copper we
have moved shortened the copper loop so
much that the fibrous now so close that
the next step for me is simply to go
fiber all the way the cost of equipment
for fiber deployment has gone down such
that the cost of labor is now the
dominant component and this means that
in Eastern Europe and a fair chunk of
southern Europe the economics have
completely changed and in most cases we
would just go all the way instead that
cell as a caveat we should also keep in
mind that for all practical purposes for
almost all countries more than fifty
percent will never ever be covered with
fiber and in those remaining areas it's
simply not economical copper will still
be the main technology before we come
back to that just tell us about some of
the other subjects that the panel
debated yes I think one classic subject
is also European regulation or European
frameworks with with regards to this and
I think here and we are differing views
but some are still short I think one
concern is that there might not be a
European answer to these questions
around infrastructure there might be in
other areas of policy or public policy
but the situation is simply too
different with regards to population
density purchasing power existing
infrastructure and on my view is that
there is no
European solution there are national
solutions at best right at first yeah
and there was a discussion around the
subsidy program upcoming subsidy program
from the european union with likely to
invest substantial amounts of money into
deploying fiber and although that sounds
as a great idea and hopefully will be a
great idea they're also risks associated
with this risks that we choose to make
inefficient investments in inappropriate
technologies in the wrong places leading
action to less coverage for a smaller
population than you would then you would
hope and this might sound
counterintuitive is a real risk now just
going back to copper versus fiber I
believe that you personally are a
convert to recent convert to fiber I am
indeed i am ii did i have spent the last
12 years evaluating fiber business cases
in various operators around the globe
and i have consistently been a fiber
skeptic and said that it's the
technology limited to certain specific I
density population were high density of
wealth areas now I have changed my mind
frankly I think I have been proven right
in the past but as of late I i must say
i have i've changed my mind and
everything changes the US and i think
the one thing that i didn't see coming
we were all thinking about these
internet of things and xrays sending
back and forth there was none of that it
was the simple fact that large
television screens became cheaper and I
never thought HD which matter because i
had a television screen that with
20-inch at 21 inch at the time but once
that became 50 or 60 suddenly HD
mattered a lot and now we have in us
forty-six percent of population are more
than two HD TVs you have almost eight
parallel connected devices for streaming
HD in parallel and when this comes and
becomes 4k which people now say we don't
need but i say wait until the screens
get bigger and they will then I think
we're in a deep mess and standalone
copper will in that case not be able
special how's the market in the Czech
Republic I know you're that you're the
incumbent operator how are you coping
with all this demand yes
I mean we are we are the marketing Czech
Republic is relatively unique in the
sense that beyond the traditional copper
incumbent and the traditional cable
player large caliber in our case UPC
there is a plethora of very small Wi-Fi
players and what they do is they
essentially have a point to multi-point
Wi-Fi antenna covering a city or it know
you'll see the town town so we have
thousands of these so thirty percent of
all the fixed broadband is provided by
operators with something like a thousand
subscribers and this is very different
different technology partly because of
this we have been relatively late in our
fibre rollout compared to some of the
other European cities but we are coming
coming strong now again I can assure you
that fantastic thank you very much for
talking to thank you so a very
interesting conversation there with
fiber converts from the Czech Republic